[Music]
did you guys have a gift registry when
you got married
no our wedding was so unconventional we
didn't do any of that [ __ ] that was that
was none of that it was really
hot all suffered a lot of [ __ ]
mosquitoes he married us our ceremony's
probably like 15 minutes we're all
barefoot that was kind of cool we ate
mcdonald's like it was too tight yeah
the swimming pool was boiling yeah yeah
why was that sweet
with the volleyball net in the middle
yeah
that's tight yo when it rained though
that [ __ ] was nice when it was we were
swimming while it was raining oh man
that was like we were in hawaii
did did you have a gift restaurant did
anybody have a gift nursery nope are you
gonna have one
i want gifts
is that cool
yeah but i was supposed to know what to
give you i'll let you know to give me
[ __ ] yeah by you having a registry no
i'm just going to text you probably i
had that for my baby shower oh
okay i see you officially okay so if
someone had something similar yeah i had
it then we know what it is that's what
normal people do yes right normal people
do that when they get married yeah i
paid a lot for other people's gift
registries yeah so apparently kylie
jenner and travis scott their wedding is
coming up their gift registry got found
on amazon
it's not on amazon
[Laughter]
so give registries get revenues could be
anywhere they could be from anything
there's target at all yeah it could be i
like the amazon ones because you can
just click for the people involved it's
so easy yeah those are really [ __ ]
what do they have a [ __ ] murcielago
or some [ __ ] that's what that's what
we're about to do we're going to arabian
horse
right
they're going to put things like a
[ __ ] giraffe
i don't know why i want animals
i haven't even seen all the items on
here
we're going to go ahead and react to
some of the [ __ ] that's on this [ __ ]
list
all right let's go so we got oh it's a
video no it's not a video but they have
the visual list of it
let's do it
a 10 grand clock get the [ __ ] out of
here what is it what it's this thing
right there
holy [ __ ] 10 grand but that's a small
clock
a six-figure fake fish
oh i like that the total of that is
what's the point of a fake fight it's
130 000. 30 grand so where do you put it
what do you mean the point of a fake
fish you have to ask that you sound like
you're poor you've never seen a fake
fish before you've never seen that like
sing songs and it goes
oh i'm in that's bass mouth dudes that's
bassmaster there's
that [ __ ] makes people happy bro those
are always six figures too i stand
corrected i'm sorry
i thought it was the fake fish that
swims inside the fish tank it might be
have you seen those they're like [ __ ]
like robot fish and then they just never
die because they're like not alive and
then they just swim back and forth holy
[ __ ]
poor people questions
oh i need paper weights too a crystal
tropical peacock worth 390 thousand
dollars what though wow
that's cool
buying they have really rich they're
guests i guess i bet all celebrities
dude i don't think you're going to
invite like i want to wait was that a
christmas of a poor person yeah there
was a crystallization how about this a
zenith one of us a baccarat zenith
chandelier worth five hundred thousand
dollars that's that one makes sense yeah
but it's weird like a chandelier makes
more sense than the [ __ ] crystal uh
peacock or whatever yeah i'll buy them
that 40. is there any practical [ __ ]
what about some airfryers they got an
airfryer in there yeah well no they got
a chest
what about like a soji rushi like the
500 one that's a lot of crystal [ __ ]
like look at this they put zojirushi on
there she's a japanese guy
please there's somebody behind me
i've been here for 17 years a crystal
cactus 36 thousand dollars i know where
to get a metal one for like 800 bucks
do you think this should let them know
do you think this is uh their version of
like when we put something that's like
super duper affordable so no one gets
inconvenienced with the price oh good
question oh
yeah we don't know what level they're at
yeah this is like they're like oh don't
spend too much on us here here's like a
chandelier i mean it could be because
what she's a billionaire right she is
yeah here's a cheap challenge there's
only five hundred thousand dollars yeah
i wonder if all those items are like art
items that we don't know about that that
go up in value eventually
rich people just function so differently
or do you think like i feel like when uh
you're not rich
um the things you ask for are things
that make sense but when you are rich
the things that you would ask for you
can so easily afford for yourself so if
you're super rich maybe you ask for the
things that you wouldn't
get for yourself you know what i'm
saying yeah no like i can afford it i
can afford a half a million chandelier
if i'm a billionaire but it's like
that's not as practical so let me ask
somebody else to buy from me they're
asking for them oh i know that feeling
yeah right well you wouldn't buy it
yourself but you would accept it as a
gift if it was like this is why this is
why they're trying to make all this
money and no creativity right because i
would have on that registry a nike
factory with a team of thai teens
yeah let's go dude but how do we
purchase that team of thai
yeah because i'm not into child labor
i'm into teen labor not child labor
that's cool man that's cool they're more
efficient
a team of thai teens sounds like someone
misread teen titans
oh a team of tag teams let's go
[Laughter]
i'm a [ __ ]
here's what you want to hear where the
cheapest thing's on the list what maybe
i could afford it a little soap dish
worth 45 bucks
i'll buy that that one is gone like that
dude yeah that's me i'm like and i bet
the richest guy bought that 100 because
he's so cheap jason chen
graham stefan's definitely invited he
got that one first
yeah dude there's lots of weird [ __ ]
there's like a bunch of different
paperweights here and they're all like
100 bucks 300 bucks who needs more than
one paperwork two hundred dollars for
use his paper bruh just get a rock right
paperweight she's a rock my guy goddamn
i like this there's this don't use the
fans
close all the windows
nine thousand dollars for a pair of
american flag arm chairs
furniture makes sense but with the
american flag on it
that's disrespectful brother do you get
this one
eleven hundred fifty dollars for uh
octagonal shaped bucket get the [ __ ] out
of here with that [ __ ] it's a bucket is
it by yeti
it's
by yeti it doesn't even say it just says
a mahogany octagonal bucket oh i thought
it was like supreme bucket or something
i like mahogany and octagonal as well
11.50 though do you guys like going to
weddings you know what this is they're
boring man
receptions it's pretty fun who likes
weddings here i enjoy weddings yeah what
what do you like about weddings
the receptions the yeah
the open bar the dance floor not the
ceremony part where the dad walks the
daughter and you're like
i'm usually already lit at that point
i'm just trying to axe over it depends
on what type of [ __ ] wedding you go
to and it also depends on the race if
it's vietnamese i'm going 100 vietnamese
weddings are the best weddings hands
down
the gangster family that comes all
tatted up and [ __ ] you don't know where
the [ __ ] they got in prison then you
have the other one because the
vietnamese guy married a white girl and
they're all proper and they're looking
at them like who the [ __ ] are these guys
it is i've been to this but it's always
a seven core seafood meal it's awesome
and then there's stuff there there's the
crab oh it's so [ __ ] the sea cucumber
the honey walnut shrimp
jellyfish or whatever the [ __ ] heineken
the hennessy
the hennessy under the table and then
you wait for the old people to leave
because they're not going to finish
their drinks and you take their [ __ ] and
then you see all the aunties take all
the centerpieces that's tight
[ __ ] the best the last viet wedding i
went to uh there was shark fin soup
there always is that
real [ __ ] and that's what i said i was
like i was like oh is this for real
and then they were like no it's fake and
then someone else said they just say
it's fake so they don't get in trouble
but it's like the real [ __ ] wow
that's fancy sneaky right have you guys
had bird's nest soup mer's nest is fire
i like bird's nest did you try it you
tried it
it's just bird barf yeah it's bird barf
oh sweet though that's all it is
regurgitating to turn into a [ __ ]
but it's not like human barf like you're
tasting human barf hey birds be eating
whatever the [ __ ] honey is
i'd rather have your barf than a bird
bar
that's wild bro i don't know that's old
you want my barf is that what you just
said anybody in general is barf i'll
give you my barf
over about
his name
it depends on what type of bird too if
it's like it's bart all right
but when you have your wedding you're
not doing any type of registry of any
sort
yeah he says he likes gifts he wants all
the gifts you're really gonna you're
really gonna person my person would you
prefer money or gifts uh nowadays money
i'll give you like golf clubs from the
thrift store
he's making offers you're gonna give him
the golf clubs all wooded and [ __ ]
knowing my friends just give me money
let's make it easy that's funny but if
you're asian though that's why you
always invite your parents friends
because they always give a gratuitous
amount of money it's always like 500
bucks that's the con of some vietnamese
weddings oh what do you mean so usually
it's an event
no it's just uh some some are cheaper
than others yeah like a buddy of mine
who just got married uh last year he
made more money even after all the
wedding expenses wow
i have that option too if i just do my
asian side wedding the way that they
want and i don't give a [ __ ] about
anything that i want we're just gonna go
to like seafood cove in westminster with
the [ __ ] dragon in the phoenix we're
gonna eat the regular meal that they
offer everybody there's a bank of hall
that they gave you the [ __ ] wife has
to dress like seven times in different
alley eyes and everything like that and
then all these uncles don't forget the
tea ceremony in the beginning or what
yeah the cheese army is probably the
only thing i hate um but all these
people will show up that your parents
invite regardless i won't know any of
them and then hopefully we'll more than
break even that's literally the like
regular game plan for a vietnamese style
wedding
so that it makes everything fun like
they crack the code for weddings
well as long as every single time you go
you have to pay anytime anytime somebody
comes to yours it's like the same things
like that code you better pay so for
your wedding is it going to be
completely vietnamese or are you adding
any elements of filipino [ __ ] oh oh uh
well she's not she doesn't have a giant
family here
so it's not the same you know what i
mean if i if i invited her whole family
here i'd be like ten people you're
ladies uh filipino filipino
i like how you ask him like he has any
say at his own wedding hey hey so she
wants a vietnamese waiting
no oh oh
what's a filipino wedding
know